what is this i heard you learned how to
fly a helicopter that sounds very
dangerous to me i mean can you fly like
if i hired you to fly me somewhere you
could do it yeah no [ __ ] yeah you can
fly on your own now they don't put
another guy in there with you this
sounds like a rich man's game no they
don't it is yeah did you own your own
helicopter no that's that's when you got
money right when you when you i just
rent them and they're expensive as hell
but then you have a thing where if you
buy it you can rent it back to the lease
it back to the school
but this but this is how it works how
rather than miles on the engine they go
by hours and every 2 200 hours there's
an overhaul where they just take the
whole [ __ ] thing apart becomes a
brand new helicopter you have to pay for
the overhaul so you're loaning the thing
out to them and it's a race against time
as you're now playing flying for 60
bucks of whack but they're taking it out
you know three four times a day with
students but while the hours on why did
you learn how to fly a helicopter i mean
how will that uh benefit you if you
don't own a helicopter and uh do you
want to do a side job as a helicopter
pilot fires wildfires what was the
thinking there yeah is this your backup
career like yeah we read about harrison
ford putting up fires and you know
flying into people's homes well yeah and
landing in their yard yeah we're not
going to read about you doing that no it
was it i was this is so [ __ ] weird i
was getting really into conspiracy
theory
right around 2008 with the banks going
down and nobody [ __ ] doing anything
to them right everybody's upside down in
the house nobody gives a [ __ ] right you
know people drowning in new orleans
nobody gives a [ __ ] but they're [ __ ]
you know i mean i wasn't one of these
conspiracy look at me i'm leaning
forward yeah but were you like buying
rice and storing it in the house
oh yeah no no no no no i i had that
thing you know where you have that
bucket of stuff and then it also comes
with a toilet oh yeah
you're [ __ ] your food and you need
it right yeah you drink your urine your
hair grows back or something right so
you were really getting ready for
armageddon no i i was i and reading that
stuff
and there's nothing behind the dollar
and all of this [ __ ] and then just
living in l.a yes and reading this stuff
that's dollar was going to collapse it's
2008 right and that um you know
it just the chaos that was going to
happen in cities and i was living in the
middle of la and which is unbelievably
claustrophobic and it takes like two and
a half hours to get out of even when it
works right forget about if society was
collapsing so i was thinking how the
[ __ ] do i get out of here and the only
way out was up and out with the
helicopter so it took me a number of
years i mean you were so [ __ ] freaked
out and so bought into like this is it
your plan you took it one step further
you said i'm gonna learn how to fly a
helicopter so i can helicopter out of
l.a up and now when the [ __ ] hits you in
a two-seater that only has enough room
for me and my wife and maybe a couple
containers of applesauce and then and
then the big thing is where are you
going well that's that's my next
question
how do you get to the helicopter i
didn't think it out i just it's just a
paranoid thought ahead sounds like the
helicopter is parked in your house you
get to the helicopter where are you
going so we can plan too i didn't know
where i was going i was just you know
when the zombies were coming up the
street i was just gonna [ __ ]
i was going to stay up in a hover until
they ate everybody and they were full
and i was going to land on like a
ralph's or something and run in a bunch
of make grab some hams and then get out
i swear to you your plan
works
yeah but if you but i don't have any i
don't have a helicopter and i have no
helipad that's the only problem
other than that it's great